ils ont refusé d'évacuer leur ville
malgré les combats à baroute environ 10%
des civils vivent toujours chez eux en
pleine lignes de front faire ses courses
se déplacer ce soigner est un défi
quotidien l'armée
ukrainienne tente régulièrement de
convaincre les habitants de partir ok
demain à 10h involontaire avec des
lunettes passera te prendre
autour de barmut l'armée russe continue
son offensive l'artillerie mais
notamment à mal la défense ukrainienne
la ville à l'est de l'Ukraine est un
nœud de communication stratégique dans
la région de Donetsk annexée par la
Russie il y a quelques semaines
quelques kilomètres au nord de Barth
mouth la préoccupation principale des
habitants et de trouver du bois pour se
chauffer ici plus de gaz ni
d'électricité alors que l'hiver approche
nous n'avons vraiment pas d'autre option
nous essayons de survivre grâce à ce
bois un sous-sol un four et du bois
c'est tout ce que nous avons
pour cette retraité la solidarité entre
voisins est essentielle tout comme
l'aide humanitaire
les autorités locales la fournissent
l'église apporte également son aide
il y a aussi des volontaires qui nous
ont apporté de la nourriture pour les
animaux
les autorités ukrainiennes proposent une
aide humanitaire à tous les habitants
même si certains ici disent n'avoir rien
reçu et ce sont oubliés